Server: May I help you, sir?
Customer: Uh, let's see.
Server: We have pan seared registry error
sprinkled with the finest corrupted data,
binary brioche, RAM sandwiches,
Conficker fitters,
and a scripting salad with or
without polymorphic dressing,
and a grilled coding kabob.
Customer: I'd like a RAM sandwich
and a glass of your finest Code 39.
Server: Would you like any desserts, sir?
Our special is tracking cookie.
Customer: I'd like a batch of some
zombie tracking cookies, thank you.
Server: Coming right up, sir.
Your food will be served shortly.
(Applause)
Maya Penn: I've been drawing ever
since I could hold a crayon,
and I've been making animated flip books
since I was three years old.
At that age, I also learned
about what an animator was.
There was a program on TV about jobs
most kids don't know about.
When I understood that an animator
makes the cartoons I saw on TV,
I immediately said, "That's what I want to be."
I don't know if I said it mentally or out loud,
but that was a greatly defining moment in my life.
Animation and art has always been my first love.
It was my love for technology that sparked the idea
for "Malicious Dishes."
There was a virus on my computer,
and I was trying to get rid of it,
and all of a sudden, I just thought,
what if viruses have their own
little world inside the computer?
Maybe a restaurant where they meet up
and do virusy things?
And thus, "Malicious Dishes" was born.
At four years old, my dad showed me
how to take apart a computer
and put it back together again.
That started my love for technology.
I built my first website myself in HTML,
and I'm learning JavaScript and Python.
I'm also working on an animated series
called "The Pollinators."
It's about bees and other
pollinators in our environment
and why they're so important.
If plants aren't pollinated by the pollinators,
then all creatures, including ourselves,
that depend on these plants, would starve.
So I decided to take these cool creatures
and make a superhero team.
(Applause)
(Foot stomp)
(Music)
(Roar)
Pollinator: Deforestsaurus! I should have known!
I need to call on the rest of the Pollinators!
(Music)
Thank you. (Applause)
All of my animations start with ideas,
but what are ideas?
Ideas can spark a movement.
Ideas are opportunities and innovation.
Ideas truly are what make the world go round.
If it wasn't for ideas, we wouldn't be
where we are now with technology, medicine,
art, culture, and how we even live our lives.
At eight years old, I took my ideas
and started my own business called Maya's Ideas,
and my nonprofit, Maya's Ideas for the Planet.
(Laughter)
And I make eco-friendly clothing and accessories.
I'm 13 now, and although I started my business
in 2008,
my artistic journey started way before then.
I was greatly influenced by art, and I wanted to
incorporate it in everything I did, even my business.
I would find different fabrics around the house,
and say, &quot;This could be a scarf or a hat,&quot;
and I had all these ideas for designs.
I noticed when I wore my creations,
people would stop me and say,
"Wow, that's really cute. Where can I get one?"
And I thought, I can start my own business.
Now I didn't have any business plans
at only eight years old.
I only knew I wanted to make pretty creations
that were safe for the environment
and I wanted to give back.
My mom taught me how to sew,
and on my back porch, I would sit and make
little headbands out of ribbon,
and I would write down the names
and the price of each item.
I started making more items like hats,
scarves and bags.
Soon, my items began selling all over the world,
and I had customers in Denmark, Italy, Australia,
Canada and more.
Now, I had a lot to learn about my business,
like branding and marketing,
staying engaged with my customers,
and seeing what sold the most and the least.
Soon, my business really started to take off.
Then one day, Forbes magazine
contacted me when I was 10 years old.
(Laughter)
They wanted to feature me and my company
in their article.
Now a lot of people ask me,
why is your business eco-friendly?
I've had a passion for protecting the environment
and its creatures since I was little.
My parents taught me at an early age
about giving back and being a
good steward to the environment.
I heard about how the dyes in some clothing
or the process of even making the items
was harmful to the people and the planet,
so I started doing my own research,
and I discovered that even
after dyeing has being completed,
there is a waste issue that gives a negative impact
on the environment.
For example, the grinding of materials,
or the dumping of dried powder materials.
These actions can pollute the air,
making it toxic to anyone or anything that inhales it.
So when I started my business,
I knew two things:
All of my items had to be eco-friendly,
and 10 to 20 percent of the profits I made
went to local and global charities
and environmental organizations.
(Applause)
I feel I'm part of the new wave of entrepreneurs
that not only seeks to have a successful business,
but also a sustainable future.
I feel that I can meet the needs of my customers
without compromising the
ability of future generations
to live in a greener tomorrow.
We live in a big, diverse and beautiful world,
and that makes me even more passionate to save it.
But it's never enough to just
to get it through your heads
about the things that are happening in our world.
It takes to get it through your hearts,
because when you get it through your heart,
that is when movements are sparked.
That is when opportunities
and innovation are created,
and that is why ideas come to life.
Thank you, and peace and blessings.
(Applause)
Thank you. (Applause)
Pat Mitchell: So, you heard Maya talk about
the amazing parents who are behind
this incredible woman. Where are they?
Please, Mr. and Mrs. Penn. Would you just -- Ah!
(Applause)